Yeah he’s sort of viewed as the founding
father of
physics basically, you can’t really get
a much bigger
deal than that for a physicist or an astronomer,
he really
was the man who invented the whole subject.
He’s a big deal because he’s the first
person to actually
use mathematics and develop mathematics so
that you
could create a theory, work out the consequences
and
compare with the experiment. So, for example,
his three
laws can be expressed mathematically, turned
into
equations and then you find out that the planets
go
round in ellipses with the sun at, one of
the focuses, foci
of the ellipse.
Sir Isaac Newton is thought to be one of the
greatest
scientists of all time, has contributed a
lot to the field.
He developed calculus; he invented a reflecting
telescope that was made from a mirror instead
of a lens.
He’s sometimes credited with having invented
the
reflecting telescope, which isn’t true.
In fact, lots of
people had sort of played around with them,
even
Galileo the first person to use one astronomically,
had
actually played around trying to make telescopes
out of
mirrors. But Newton’s great genius is that
he actually
built a practical one, one that actually worked.
What Newton did was incredible, and a lot
of the things
that he came up with are the basis of understanding.
For
example, when he was a student, there were
light
beams going through the shutters of his window
and he
put it into a prism and showed that light
split into a
spectrum and as a result of that he could
explain why
rainbows came about. He was able to turn the
mathematics and do the experiments so as to
analyse
the natural world in a way nobody had done
before.
But he was a bit of a strange character; he
wasn’t an
extrovert; he didn’t really get along with
people very
well.
I’ve read that he had a couple of nervous
breakdowns;
he was a very, very sensitive person. So when
the
calculus, his mathematics came up, he and
Leibniz both
invented complementary aspects to it. And
they didn’t,
he couldn’t see that Leibniz works on the
integral
calculus was complimentary to his work on
the
differential calculus. He just wanted to rubbish
Leibniz
all his life and so it was as competition
and he was very
arrogant and aggressive about things like
that.
Also with Robert Hook, who was a wonderful
experimentalist, and wrote the standard treatise
on
optics, he was an enemy as far as Newton was
concerned and he would try to do anything
to damage
Hook’s reputation. So he wouldn’t have
been a nice
colleague to have.
One of the things that Newton is most famous
for is
saying that, you know, if he’s seen further
than anyone
else it was only because he was ‘standing
on the
shoulders of giants’ and this was always
viewed as a
self-deprecating remark that he was showing
respect to
those who had come before him. More recently,
it has
been suggested, that he was actually just
having a go at
Hook who was famously very short. And so there
are
aspects of him that he was a little bit strange,
he was
not necessarily a particularly nice man, he
was
incredibly secretive, he would keep stuff
hidden away for
years and years just because he was afraid
that other
people were going to steal his ideas.
But he was a scientist through and through
and he used
himself to experiment with a lot of different
projects, so
when he was working with lenses and mirrors
and
optics, he actually wondered why our eyes
are such
sophisticated lenses and so he actually took
an ice pick
and kind of probed behind his eye to figure
out how it
worked so well. Kind of gross, I hate that
story.
Isaac Newton’s a fascinating character because
he’s
famous for writing the Principia Mathematica,
which
certainly changed the face of physics. But
Newton wrote
more about theology and prophecy and alchemy
than he
ever did about science and mathematics. And
that’s the
extraordinary thing, and Newton had very,
very
eccentric theological views, views about Christianity.
Isaac Newton also liked to look at the sun
to see how
that affected your eyes. Of course as children
we all
hear ‘don’t look at the sun too long because
you’ll go
blind.’ Well he did actually look at the
sun for quite a
long time and then he remarked in his journal
that he
saw the image of the sun in his eye while
he was
sleeping, or while he was going to sleep even,
for about
three days. So it definitely does damage to
your eye,
believe it.
But Newton also rejected the traditional Christian
view
that God is not just an individual, that God
is a
community of Father, Son, and Holy Spirit,
and we call
that the Trinity: three persons in one God.
And Newton
rejected the view of the church that God is
Trinity. It’s
ironic because Newton was a fellow of Trinity
College,
Cambridge, so in his very working environment
the
institution that he worked for was dedicated
to a
doctrine, a teaching, in which he himself
did not believe.
Well when I first came to Nottingham, I lived
way out in
Lincolnshire and somebody told us that his
house was at
Woolsthorpe, near Colsterworth, and we drove
out there
and I got the wrong Woolsthorpe, there are
two out
there. Eventually we found the right one and
in those
days, this is over thirty years ago, the house
was owned
by somebody and you had to go at a certain
time and
she would open the door for you and you could
go round
and see all the traces he’d left behind
because he got
his compasses and he’d scratched pictures
of the
Cathedral in Grantham on the wall. So I remember
that
vividly.
Gradually this aura came to settle around
Newton that
he was the holder of secrets and the Principia
was, as it
were, this was Newton’s scripture. And Newton
himself
fostered this, this reputation for being some
sort of
prophet of God and he did write under some
pseudonyms, one of which was the pseudonym
IEHOUAS
SANCTUS UNUS, Jehovah the name of God, the
Holy
One, which he believed was an anagram of the
Latin
version of his own name, ISSAACHUS NEUUTONUS
-
IEHOUAS SANCTUS UNUS.
I thought a manor house would be a big Elizabethan
manor, but it’s actually a small pokey little
place, it’s not
much bigger than an ordinary semi. Only on
one floor,
or maybe two floors, it wasn’t that grand.
I mean think of the Da Vinci Code today and
Dan Brown,
I mean there is nothing new in all that, is
there
something we are not being told? It’s a
bit like a
conspiracy theory, and can we get underneath
it all? And
just as Newton thought he was trying to decode
the
Universe, the mind of God, by this mathematics,
so he
thought there were all other codes all over
the place,
including his own name and anagrams that needed
decoding to see what they revealed. So knowledge
had
to be prized, prized open to get the secrets
and only the
very clever, only the wise, could really find
out exactly
what was going on in the mind of God.
He was, you know, he had all the trappings
of a genius
in the sense that as well as being incredibly
smart and
coming up with incredibly innovative ideas,
he also
clearly had his eccentricities as well.
Would you give him a job here?
I think, hmm, that’s a good question, I
wonder how he
would succeed in, in academia today? I don’t
know is
the short answer. A lot of the things that
these
eccentricities the way he tended to rub people
up the
wrong way, the fact that he didn’t publish
things, he hid
them away for years at a time, you know in
academia
today, the way you succeed is by getting your
ideas out
there and by publishing things and showing,
you know,
showing your, your peers your fellow scientists,
what
you are doing. And his approach to science
and keeping
stuff very much to himself and not wanting
to share with
people really wouldn’t work terribly well
in the way that
science works today.
He was really quite phenomenal in his prime
and later
on he dabbled in alchemy and all sorts of
things and got
into religious arguments. He was a very strange
and
complicated person. Not the sort that you
want to go
down the pub with.
I’d go to the pub with him!
And then you’d start arguing in your Australian
way to
wind him up and see what you could get out
of him for a
video for Sixty Symbols.
If I could make a video of Isaac Newton, Roger,
I
wouldn’t be sitting here with you.
LAUGHS
Quite, quite!